Japanese food is amazing
in that it's so simple.
It is made up of so
many little dishes
that it feels like little tiny
gifts while you're eating.
When I'm not in
the kitchen, I feel
very self-conscious about how
to express who I am as a person.
When I really want
to express something,
it's so easy to do it
through the medium of food.
Kaiseki has such a long
history, but recognizing that,
we've decided to do a
modern version of kaiseki,
because traditional
places in Japanese history
do not necessarily
have space for women.
My definition of modern kaiseki
is taking traditional kaiseki
and incorporating
it with new ideas,
but always remembering
the core philosophy,
which is honor the ingredient,
be grateful, and do the best
to showcase those ingredients.
I'm Niki Nakayama, and
this is my MasterClass.
I'm looking forward
to showing you
how to fabricate some
fish, how to steam a dish,
how to make dashi,
the foundation
of all Japanese cuisine.
This is Carole, my wife at
home, and my partner at work,
and we're going to talk about
different Japanese cooking
techniques, and how you
can enjoy it as a family,
or as individual dishes.
I'm going to show you this very
simple process of washing rice.
Letting it sit and
rest for at least 20
to 30 minutes is key to a
really beautiful batch of rice.
We'll be teaching you
how to cut some sashimi,
how to make some tempura, and
how to grill over binchōtan.
It looks so beautiful,
so welcoming,
and there's so much life to it.
As you're learning
these techniques,
be kind to yourself,
let yourself
do things that don't always
work, but always learn
from them.
What I hope people who
cook try to communicate
when they make a
meal is a feeling
of love and appreciation.
I think it's such an
expression of giving,
and it's such an
expression of care.
That is what I love
most about food.
Nakayama Niki to moushimasu.
Kore ga watashi no MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]